now i was accused uh last week and i
i don't know this is up to the listener
to decide but i was accused by
my compatriots the chilled chums of not
being very chill
and uh and and being sort of ratcheted
up
and uh coming in hot and
that may be the case i don't know i'm
i'm humble enough to accept that i am uh
despite incredible powers uh i
am a human and flawed and so it's
possible that i was
not chill last week and if that's the
case
uh i uh i'm sorry and i will try to be
more chill hmm this episode i'll do the
best i can
so with that in mind let's uh let's
begin
uh sona it's nice to have you on the
show it's very nice to be here
well you don't yeah okay you seem you
see
okay i don't wanna we were just talking
about
murder in the summer and so i realized
that's not a very chill
topic to bring up so i have nothing to
say right now
well i have
before we came on the air uh on the air
before we pressed record whatever
is the correct term matt what's the
correct term i think press record but
you know it's a general term
i think people forgive you for that okay
i don't understand
uh the podcast format i actually still
don't understand
television after doing it for 27 years
so uh
you'll forgive me uh if i if i'm a
little clumsy in my wording
but the point we were before we started
this episode we were all just chatting
and of course
i would say the one thing the three of
us really have in common
is maybe a lot of people have this but
we all are very obsessed with murder
uh i love and
uh i don't love murder i mean that's a
terrible thing to say
uh yes in a perfect world i would be
able to murder
wait what uh but i understand that there
are social conventions and laws and
uh i i don't want to go to prison so i
will not murder
despite my sick thing to say okay bite
my insatiable desire for
and the murder voice in my head that
says murder murder
you know it's what you want you know
it's what you're good at sometimes
that's not just in your head by the way
that you say that out loud
by the way i'm i'm saying this i think
in a very chill way
you did you did come in fairly chill
this episode i want to say you didn't
come in hot
and you know what my tone is still very
chill as i tell you
my greatest my greatest desire in life
uh is to uh to wantonly uh
murder rob other people of their lives
and get away with it
so there you go that's uh and i'm just
saying that as a chill chum
yeah before you even said that if you
did murder and someone
came up to me and said hey did you ever
think he'd be the kind of guy you'd
murder
i'd be like yes absolutely he talks
about murder all the time
i'm obsessed with murder and what's what
is interesting
is that sona you know i hired sona
um we all do things we laid a regret but
i
i did hire i did hire someone
no i'm kidding i'm kidding i'm kidding
i'm necessary terrible unnecessary
terrible i love you sono but i did hire
you
and one of the things we did early on
because i had just moved out to los
angeles this is like 11 years ago
uh we just moved out to los angeles sona
and i were
i think we were somewhere in the car
together because we had to do something
and you said
oh wait this is near the
the you know the scene of the first
manson murders
uh you know the on cielo drive we were
on benedict
and canyon which two of us were really
like oh we've got to go up there and see
it which i know sounds ghastly and
uh and and everything but we were both
we both knew every single detail of
you know manson and the whole history of
manson
and that's when we realized okay this is
something we have in common we have
many things that were that were aren't
in common
uh we're we're not alike um i could go
on at length about those
uh nope no move on okay
yeah i cherish america oh
wow okay
i uh whatever but you were telling a
nice
story about us looking at the house
where yeah what a nice story what a
nice nice tail of us retracing retracing
the steps
uh uh but we knew all the people in the
car we knew then
you know about what they did the next
night we knew we knew everything
and then i realized that whenever i'm
traveling or going anywhere the first
thing i try and look for
is a forensic files because they show
one
after another after another after
another and i just watch those
and i'm fascinated with that stuff and
matt you have some interest in murder
yeah i suppose i grew up in the place
where the night stalker
did his night stalking in whittier and
so it was really
kind of big in the community obviously
at the time
right that was a big story that was a
good thing yeah
and my wife was in a play with a guy who
did a double murder and dismembered the
bodies and spread them throughout a park
oh my god wait this
is not chill